okay
um welcome everyone thank you for having
me here and thank you for the organizers
for inviting me here it's a wonderful
occasion for me to come back to Stanford
after kovid after a little bit of time
and today I'm going to talk about topic
that I'm very fond of and excited about
which is tactile sensing and I will go
through different aspects of touch why
why it's an important topic and going
from the perception to the understanding
and ultimately how do you start for
interacting mostly through robots and
just to give you a little bit of
background about me and what are my
interests
um my my background is at the really
conjunction of machine learning and
Robotics and a lot of the research that
I've been doing the last few years have
been motivated by the fact that
um in the last decade there has been
really impressive development in in the
use of machine learning and and applying
this type of techniques to a really
large number of fields including some
pretty impressive reinforcement learning
on on games and and on Robotics
and some of the questions that I'm
generally interested in asking is how do
we scale this type of algorithms to more
complex real-world applications what are
the really the aspects that requires to
be improved algorithmically so that we
can ultimately achieve you know
impressive results in fields like
robotics decision making Finance
biological science and such and in this
talk I'll be focusing mostly on robotic
which is my main field of application of
the algorithms that I developed
and the reason why robot I think it's
um it's it's it's a little bit
self-explanatory but for me what robots
can bring to our society the benefits
that robot can have are huge what I
would like to see in 10 years 20 years
is robotics everywhere in Industrial
Automation I want to replace every
single children
mining coal in Thailand with a robot
that can do this without having to break
their you know their their bones over
headless shifts of work I want to be
able robots to to help with disaster
relief with all of this you know weather
changes that we have nowadays which are
getting more and more violent
I want robots to be able to explore the
world
both the underwater world and other
planets it's very likely that no we
already have actually seen this that the
first human artifacts on Mars are not
people are robots that we can control
from thousands of miles away
and finally Madison and elder care with
the growing elder population that we
have in westernized societies is
becoming more and more important to be
able to provide robots that can help and
assist elders and general population
however if we look critically at what is
the state of Robotics and this is these
are some videos from the DARPA
competition in 2015 and just to give an
idea of what we are looking at here
these are the best team in the world
these are teams that spend two three
years in some cases with hundreds of
people working extremely hard on having
robots going through different uh you
know paths and tasks and challenges and
the type of errors that we see the type
of failure modes that we can observe in
this type of very sophisticated robots
are failures that we would never
associate with the word intelligence
it's not the type of values that we
would never associate with you know even
kids my three years old kids will never
fail like this in a way that you know
for a human is stupid you know so what
are we missing why is you know how can
we help robotics through the use of
machine learning and artificial
intelligence and even more what do we
need in order to be able to eventually
ultimately have meaningful interaction
between uh you know humans and robots in
a safe manner in a way that is
interactive really
and I I believe that there are many
challenges that we will have to address
over the next decades but and this like
these challenges are really all over the
Spectrum from from Hardware design all
the way to control software and
ultimately reasoning and planning and
some of these aspects that I'm
personally sort of interested in are
things like multi-modal sensing
optimized Hardware design and quick
adaptation to new tasks and all of these
fields are different uh sort of source
of inspiration for my research but in
this particular talk I'll be focusing
almost exclusively into touch sensing as
a way to address the lack of sensing
that current robots have and as a way to
explore the multimodal nature of of
interactions that we as a humans have
and just to reiterate or maybe to get
started really about touch touch is a
crucial sense in our everyday life we
might barely realize this because we are
very much used to it and we give it for
granted but every time that we we grasp
an object we actually are extensively
using our sense of touch in order to
measure contact forces between our body
and the world around it we are
estimating object properties we are
estimating a lot of information also
about how the different forces are
balancing and ultimately in in a world
where you know Dynamics is everything
that matter as we interact with the
world with true forces it seems very
unnatural the fact that our robots are
currently not able to sense force in the
first place and if we want to be able to
accurately sense forces and to control
them we need to have robots that are
able to perceive the world through touch
and here is a very famous video from the
Department of Ronald Johansson where
they would essentially ask people to do
very simple tasks like Latina match and
then they would anesthetize their sense
of touch while keeping their motor
control capabilities and what we can
observe is that humans all this this
subject would immediately lose the
probability of doing this very trivial
task and this is really an indication of
how heavily uh you know the the motor
control policies that these people are
using actually make use of touch and how
are this tasks are without
now touch sensing uh for for robots or
as a digital sense it's actually a
really hard task and there are several
reasons why this is the case
um the main one is really the fact that
it's a very interdisciplinary field by
its own nature because it requires a
vertical integration between all the way
from you know what is the hardware
substrate that we use to sense touch and
then how do we make sense of it and how
do we integrate touch in a control Loop
which might traditionally use only
private perceptive information or vision
and ultimately in which application do
we deploy it and what historically has
been happening is that different Labs
have been focusing at different levels
of this vertical integration but has
always been very difficult to integrate
these different levels has been
historically very difficult to reuse
solutions that were of a dock to build
on top of this something that is more
meaningful
and effectively this lead to having a
lot of labs that do amazing work but
that keep Reinventing the wheel over and
over again because nobody else is going
to then make use of what they built to
do something more
and this also leads from a practical
standpoint to a very high entrance bars
from new researchers because you need to
be able to in many cases to build your
own sensors if you want to do research
on this or you need to be able to have a
very large set of expertise if you want
to be able to you know use prototype to
somebody else
so one of the fundamental questions that
I'm going to try to answer with this
talk today is how can we lower this
entrance bar how can we improve
reproducibility in the field and
ultimately accelerate research
by reusing existing components that
different Labs can can build innovate
and create
and all of this will point to the fact
that as a community of touch sensing we
need standardization and I will very
strongly argue for the need of creating
an ecosystem of tools that can be openly
used and accessed and built upon from
from from from the whole research
community
and to give a little bit also of our of
our way of how I frame internally to
myself into the people I work with this
type of work
um I want to give a little bit of
historical perspective
um the way that I think about touch is
not only us at all let's give robot
touch but it's really us creating a new
field of digitalization of touch as a
sensor modality in the same way that in
the at the end of the 1800 the mass
availability of of telephone for the
first time enabled people to uh you know
essentially record audio transfer it
over long distances and then play it
back on the other side of the world this
created the opportunity for new fields
of of computational science like audio
processing and more recently with the
with the boom of AI natural language
processing and this has given incredible
type of
abilities to our machines nowaday that
you can talk to it and they understand
what you actually mean and a similar
trend and has been enabled in around the
1990s with the first mass production of
digital camera sensors and again having
cheap reliable sensors enable the
creation of a field of computational
science dedicated to making sense of
vision
ultimately field that are extremely
successful like computer vision and
every one of you nowadays has for sure
cameras in in your pocket in your phone
you have tens of them probably you know
around your everyday life and this
enable again to cheaply and reliably
digitize images transfer them over
distance and essentially replaying them
back onto on the first screen and I
believe that now in this decade we have
the possibility of having a similar path
for touch with the first cheap reliable
and Mass manufacturable uh digital
sensors for touch I believe that what we
will see in the next decade is really
the building of a new computational
field of field of computation of science
dedicated to make sense of touch
dedicated to be able to digitize touch
record it transfer it and replaying it
back on the other side of the world and
this will ultimately lead to I believe a
lot of uh sort of wide scale
applications into our societies and I
will very briefly touch on this later on
in the talk
so given that this is the way that I I
try to frame what we are really looking
at in you know with the research on
tactile sensing what are the important
aspects that in practice we need to
implement and we need to execute on
the four pillars that we identified and
that we typically like to think about
are for for making touch sense
impractical in the real world are
Hardware the fact that we need to have
good Hardware which is reliable which is
cheap which is able to sense the things
that we care about
once we have this we need to be able to
process this data we need to be able to
extract informations we need to be able
to make sense of touch by processing and
I will mostly speak in this talk about
the use of AI for processing this type
of uh this this type of inputs because
this is where you know what I'm
interested in and and because of the
specific type of sensors that I'll be
talking in this talk
and then simulation simulation is
generally a very important part of any
scientific discipline
uh benchmarking data set is also very
crucial because in this moment we don't
have good Benchmark for touch we don't
have large scale data sets which are
widely available and these are very
important step stones for the growth of
any scientific community
and finally I will be talking about
applications of touch in the real world
and a little bit about Community which
is something that I'm very fond of and I
think it's very very important
but let's start from Hardware
Hardware tactile sensors in robotics is
a field that has hundreds maybe
thousands of sensors out there Mark
probably has made hundreds of them in
different ways
alone but essentially we can see that
there are if you look at the literature
there is really a huge plethora of
potential tactile sensors but what is I
think the failure Point here is the fact
that the large majority of them always
remain at the stage of prototypes a lab
spent a couple of years a bunch of time
and money on building a sensor you build
one perhaps two and once the project is
done or the PHD is done you take it
yourself if and that's it this
technology is never going to be used
ever again
and this is a very it's it's a huge pity
and it's also a huge waste
um and this leads to the fact that from
our commercial point of view if you want
to buy tactile sensors nowadays there is
an extremely limited Choice there are
probably three or four sensors that you
would seriously consider and most of
them are probably more expensive than
you can afford anyway
so
this is this is a big problem from
Hardware perspective and this happened
the whole vertical stock because without
Reliable Hardware it's very hard to do
anything else now the important factors
typically in deciding tactile sensing
Hardware or the way that you you can
classify Hardware are a few the first
one is of course availability you want
to have sensors which are widely
available that you can buy off the shelf
without having to to wait a long time
the second one is costs cost of tactile
sensors can be very diverse but in many
cases it's very expensive
form factor you might want to have
sensors that look that is flat and look
like skin or you might want to have
sensors that are more like fingertips or
anywhere in between and this form factor
play very often an important role in the
specific applications that you might
care about so
finally capabilities what is this
tactile sensor measuring what are the
type of output that you will get out of
this sensor some sensor will only return
to normal forces other sensor will
return new numbers that are not even uh
that don't even have a physical meaning
and we will see that some of them
returns your images so what are you
getting back what is the resolution what
is this frequency and so on and finally
reliability unlike digital cameras
unlike telephones in the moment when you
have a tactile sensor this tactile
sensor will inevitably incur into a huge
amount of wear and tear because
literally every sampling that you are
taking of the world around you will ruin
the sensors because you are applying
forces and you are somehow breaking it
so how do you make a sensor that can
withstand thousands or hundreds of
thousands or millions of interaction and
the solution that we have in nature is
amazing is that we have self-healing
fingers that you know grow back if you
if the Skins get scratched well we don't
quite have this type of Technology yet
in tactile sensing
so the type of sensors that I'm going to
discuss today more in depth are the
so-called vision-based tactile sensors
and I want to give you an intuition of
what is the principle of how they work
the idea is a fairly old idea it was
actually proposed several times in the
80s but it's very very smart the idea is
that you want to have a camera which can
be a normal cell phone camera which is
essentially looking at a piece of
silicon or an elastomer and then you
have structured light typically RGB
colors that are shining onto this
elastomer now whenever you're touching
this elastomer this will create the
formations internally in the way that
the light is reflected back to the
camera and will in practice create
Shadows of different colors depending
from the geometry and and the force that
is being applied to this elastomer
um and this is an extremely cool
technology because has virtually no
moving part the Silicon is the only
moving part which solve a lot of the
problems about reliability of the wiring
about reliability of the electronics and
and the manufacturing because it's very
easy we know how to manufacture camera
at scale
now what we did in 2020 is that we open
source the first
mass-producible meteorized
um high resolution Vision based tactile
sensor and this is how a digit look like
this is a sensors that was designed from
the scratch for
democratizing touch in the sense that we
wanted the sensor which is easy to
manufacture you can actually 3D print it
at home everything is online available
so you can literally go home 3D printed
buy a piece of electronic from a
standard PCB way plug it in and the
sensor will basically work now this was
essentially designed to be cheap
reliable mass manufacturable and really
accessible to anybody this was our
intention and the type of sensor
readings that you get out of Digit is
something that looks like this
so you can see this is for example a
piece of velcro and you can see the
individual teeth of the of the velcro so
the special resolution that you get out
of Digit is about 15 Micron which is
fairly revolutionary if we compare to
traditional Technologies for tactile
sensing like capacitive sensors and
although you get these strange patterns
of light you can effectively see a lot
of details you can see a lot of really
nice things and you also have this nice
sort of 2D style of image which we will
see is actually very advantageous for
Pro
processing after using machine learning
methods and just to give a curse
comparison against the leading
commercial product which is the biotech
the biotech and and the digit are both
meteorized sensors that can be mounted
on a multi-finger robotic hand
but the biotech has 29 or 19 depending
from the model point of contact so sort
of you can think of this in terms of
pixels of resolution while the digit has
about three order of magnitude more and
at the same time uh if you want to buy a
biotech this is going to cost you
fifteen thousand dollars while building
a digit is a fraction of this it's
effectively three order of money to do
more data 40 order of money to the less
money which is pretty great and our
digit is also open source so anybody can
download it anybody can modify it and
you can build it at all and so far the
the most interesting things for us has
been that over a thousand to thousands
of University have actually reproduced
these sensors on their own but we also
partners with the with the gel site Inc
which is a startup in Boston to actually
have the sensor commercially available
and you can effectively go to their
website and buy it and it's shipped to
your atom without any need for expertise
knowledge on how to you know 3D print
things if this is not your thing
and overall in the first 10 months we
sold over 1 000 of these cents or making
it the most widely available tactile
sensor in the robotic World which I
think is pretty great for a sensor that
costs 300 bucks
so
after we have the hardware let's move on
to simulation simulation is generally a
really important topic for any
scientific Fields because it allows you
to play with things it allows you to you
know benchmark your your algorithms it
allow you to measure progress and and
doing fast prototyping however what we
see in traditional
simulators is that it's very hard to
simulate something like addition based
tactile sensor because typically the
more contact points you are trying to
simulate the slower your simulator will
get and already with a few hundreds
contact points uh traditional simulator
like gazebo will essentially go much
slower than real time making it the
simulator sort of Define the purpose of
you know being assimilation the first
time in the first place so what we
proposed in open source uh actually in
last year
is a new type of simulator which we call
tacto which is explicitly designed for
simulating vision-based tactile sensor
and by making a couple of smart
sort of adjustment under the hood we can
actually simulate fairly complicated
scenarios at hundreds of frames per
second
with the while still getting high
resolution images of how the contact
would look like
and the the nice things about this
simulator is that again was designed to
be open source so it's publicly
available but it's also modular so it
can be interior integrated with any
physics engines of your choice uh
whether this is mujoko by Bullet or
Isaac Jim and at the same time can be
integrated with different sensor
configuration so if I now build a new
sensor with a completely different shape
it's in theory possible to just write a
configuration file plug it in and have
it simulated and here for example we
have some simulation for a digit sensor
and this is another sensor called Omni
attack
which is actually being the real sensor
this was not you know something that we
hard coded uh this is actually a
something that naturally rise because of
the distribution of Lights which is
pretty cool and the nice things about
the simulator is that it's actually
fairly realistic not completely
realistic but if we compare images from
the simulation and from the real sensor
it's qualitatively there I would say
that it's kind of okay for something
that again can run at hundreds of hours
per second this is great this is what we
want fast maybe not accurate but good
enough
so once we have the hardware and we have
a way of simulating this Hardware
what we care about is processing how do
we make sense of all of these images how
do we make sense of this huge amount of
data that we are getting from our sensor
and this is a very tricky problem and
this is I believe the crucial points
that will
differentiate the efforts that are going
nowadays on in tactile sensing compared
to the past is that once we have
standardized the hardware and the
simulation we can now focus on how do we
make sense of this and really what I'm
aiming at is the fact that we will have
to create a new field of computational
science which we call Touch processing
whose goal will be to make sense of
touch and some of the questions that
we'll have to deal with will be
questions like what type of features do
we want to extract what is the
equivalent of a sift feature that in
computer vision are widely used for
touch
we had a discussion with Morrow before
about you know should we use images
should we extract Optical flow should we
use stress Fields what are the
meaningful representation for touch that
can be also generalizable between
different sensors and even more what are
the computational structures that we can
exploit for processing touch in Vision
we know of the 2D structures that we
have in an image in in audio we know of
the temporal structures that we have in
in audio and sentences but touch is more
than this because it incorporates both
structural information where we have a
3D World which is mapped through a 2d
manifold that we have sensing we have a
temporal structure where vibrations and
slippage is heavily influenced over time
and we also have
multi-modality because our skin is
actually made of many different senses
that we are integrating and again touch
is a local sense where we are only are
looking we can measure what we are
touching so it's much more active as a
sense compared to Vision which is
instead Global because it gives you
Global Information about what you are
seeing but it's virtually passive
because you have no way of influencing
directly what you are looking at
or at least not really
so all of this will result in a number
of questions which are as of today
unanswered but it will be crucial in
making touch
practical and useful in the real world
and as a first stop toward trying to
answer these questions
um we also open source a library which
is called pytouch which is the first
Library dedicated to essentially touch
processing using machine learning models
and the idea here is that we want to
create the what
is the equivalent of opencv but for
touch rather than for vision we want to
have a tool which can be where every
practitioners goes to which is easy to
use where people can attach different
type of sensors as an input to a
standardized interface and where they
can then go and use and provide to the
community different models that provide
different functionalities and once you
have this then it becomes much easier to
really starting to explore questions
about you know is this sensor better
than this other sensor is this model
better than this other model and really
comparing things which are Apple to
Apple
so I will skip over some of the features
of by touch the only one that I want to
aim point is the fact that we see
pytouch as a a service is the fact that
in this moment if you download Pi touch
you you know you get a digit you plug it
in USB you download pytouch and you can
with two lines of code you can
essentially just Define you know I'm I
have a digit sensor here connected and I
now want a model which detectives there
is touch and pytouch comes with
pre-trained models that you can directly
download or are downloaded in the
background if you if you just request
this so now having a sensor
that can directly give you
functionalities in 10 minutes after you
you you unwrap it it's actually possible
through a smart use of standardized
hardware and standardized software
so and this sort of start to uh also
enabling us to ask scientific questions
and one of the scientific questions that
we mostly as a curiosity try to answer
in this in this work is whether for
example we can learn features that are
generalizable across different
vision-based tactile sensor and the idea
is that if we use three different
tactile sensors like digit omnitark and
gel site and learn a pre-trained model
using this pre-trained model to then
identify having a task like touch
detection will yield to better
performance compared to only using data
from that particular sensor that we are
using uh at deployment time and this is
really cool because it really starts
aiming to the to some of these questions
of what is a generalizable features for
touch is there even such things as a
generalizable features of touch and the
answer seems to be that yeah probably
there is because a joint model does
better than something that is trained
only on that particular sensor
so finally the fourth pillar of our
ecosystem is Benchmark and data sets
benchmarking data sets are crucial for
any healthy scientific Community
they are extremely important for
measuring progress are extremely
important for being able to
with the data set also provide tools to
people that are not interested in
working exclusively in Hardware
and so far
it essentially has been a desert in the
sense that we don't really know what are
the Benchmark different papers evaluate
sensors in different ways and in many
cases these are not standardized
benchmarks that are easy to reproduce
and at the same times there are very
very very few data sets that are
publicly available and this means that
it's extremely hard to evaluate models
or to really make use of any of this
data that other people collected so
these are two
um really important topics and I hope
that in the future we'll be able to make
progress in these fields a lot more but
just one of the very small contribution
that we did was that in together with
the release of our simulator tacto we
also released uh this standard Benchmark
for predicting grass stability where the
idea is that we want to be able to
detect whether this object will still be
in my fingers after I erase it and we
can now do this in simulation and more
importantly we can do it at a scale
which is Unthinkable in Hardware because
we can now collect millions of grasp of
an object in simulation and this is
qualitatively uh
different than being able to collect
5000 which is the largest data set that
has been collected in the real world it
allow us to test hypotheses and to train
models in a qualitatively different way
and this is really just I believe the
start of having more Benchmark also in
simulation
so
at this point I will switch over and
spend the last 10 minutes talking about
applications
um I believe that touch is going to have
a really important role in a very wide
range of applications and some of the
one that I'm personally most interested
in include things like prosthesis if we
are able to send starch we can give
people that lost their limbs the
capability back of you know being able
to censor the world around them being
able to grasp objects better being able
to walk more stably on different
surfaces and so on and I think that this
is already worth it just for this
but there are of course also other
fields of applications there is this
whole idea of the metaverse where you
want to be able to also physically
interact over the distance with
different people whatever that means
you have applications potential
application in e-commerce in the same
way that nowadays you can take a picture
of an object and say hey search for this
object I want to buy the same one I hope
that one day we will be able to you know
take a digit touch a sweater and say hey
buy me an object which has the same
thread or the same softness as my
sweater
um or maybe you're will be able to touch
your skin and say hey can you suggest me
what's the best you know beauty product
for my skin or things like this
anything that can be measured
physically it's likely to be a
commercial applications uh for you know
for a tactile sensor and finally
robotics which is of course where my
heart stand and I believe that robots
very heavily need touch in order to be
able to do a lot of tasks and specific
tasks in robotics which I believe are
important are things like agricultural
robotics where there is really no need
like strawberry picking is still done
entirely manually because uh you know
strawberries are fragile and with
traditional robots you would just
squeeze the strawberry and make it
unusable if we could use tactile sensor
to be more gentle in speaking
strawberries and we know we can you know
why don't we deploy this instead of
having people uh essentially having to
quit after five years because of their
back for bending down and doing
strawberries peaking and medical
robotics were in a lot of application
for uh tell a surgeon to be able to
sense the tissue that you are cutting or
be able to sense if there is cancer or
not these are still very much manual
operations and if we can digitize the
sense of touch then it's very likely
that we can also digitize some of these
specific tasks and applications
uh you know breast cancer why not using
tactile sensor for doing this
automatically instead of having to rely
on expertise human expertise
and
spending one reward on touch for the
metaverse
I want you to realize how
um touch is effectively the most
social and emotional sense that we have
in our life there is nothing that is
equivalent to be able to you know hug a
loved one or touch a loved one and the
fact that we are not able to digitize it
it's it's a very big limitation over
what is possible in terms of being able
to convey emotions in order to be able
to convey different state of Minds so
some of the questions that I'm broadly
interested is how can we sense calibrate
and reproduce starch over the distance
and really hear the contributions that
we have been you know that we can
provide as a basic research team is on
the first part so how do we essentially
collect sends and how do we make sense
of this you know I don't work with
Optics at all I hope that somebody else
will and will you know have digits on
the other side of this
and
just just to give one more word about
this
um actually in 2015 we had a fun paper
with some students of mine at the time
where we were using tactile sensors uh
very primitive at the time tactile
sensors to provide optic feedback to our
glove which was used in a system for
first person teleporation so we
essentially had a Oculus Rift where you
could see through the eyes of the robot
you could control the neck a movement
through just your head and then you had
a connect for detecting the pulse of the
Rob of the person and mapping it onto
this complex humanoid robot and then
through the Optics you could feel the
sensations of what you were touching
although in our case we had very
primitive optic feedback because we were
just using vibration Motors to
essentially provide different levels of
forces so and as you know vibration
Motors are actually really a bad idea
for providing Optics because humans get
used to vibrations so after a few
seconds you don't even perceive that you
know it's vibrating anymore but it was a
funny applications and you know this was
almost a decade ago so a long time
anyway finally robot learning this is
the what I'm actually you know mostly
working on nowadays there are plenty of
applications of really at the
conjunction between use of touch machine
learning and robot control and some of
the kind of things that we have been
doing in the past is to be able to
predict if a grasp is is a good grasp
you know before lifting before applying
the vertical force is this going to be a
reliable grasp or is this object going
to fall down and once you decide that
this is maybe not a good grasp how do I
adjust my fingers so that I have a grasp
which hopefully it's more robust and
more reliable uh also learning a
multimodal representation which can
transfer from vision and touch as a
humans if you look at an object you can
guesstimate fairly well how this is
going to feel when you touch it and visa
versa if you're blindfolded and you
touch an object it chances are that you
can estimate how this is gonna look
visually and potentially also you know
mechanically with the material you're
touching and so on and then also a
reconstruction of surfaces was from just
touch and vision and touch but one
application that I think it's kind of
funny that we did more recently and we
are going to present this in Japan in
next month it's actually using touch for
learning how to play piano better if
anybody of you play instruments you know
how important is touch in being able to
modulate uh you know sounds in in your
instrument at least in piano it's
important I used to play child law I can
guarantee the two things with channel
it's important
so we essentially use in simulation our
tactile sensors to be able to play
scores better and better by being able
to modulate intensity force and time
better
it was it's just in simulation so far
but I would love to see this on a rear
robot one day
um
also another application which I think
it's very cool
um from 2020 is being able to manipulate
small marbles glasses this is a task
which seems for humans it's relatively
easy but for robots it's actually
extremely hard and the reason is because
you need at the same time being able to
move a marble between your two fingers
but you also need to be able to modulate
the force between them and the marble so
because if you apply too much force
the marble will will be squeezed out
from its position if you apply to little
Force you will lose the marble because
of gravity so you need to be actually
doing very very fine manipulation at the
border between you know of friction that
actually allow you to to move and keep
the ball between your fingers and in
order to do this we actually used fairly
Advanced machine learning algorithm
items specifically in this paper we use
a model based reinforcement learning
algorithms where we were taking raw
images from the sensor and we were
essentially learning a lot in space or
feature representation if you are a deep
learning person and then use this for
making predictions into the future by
learning a forward Dynamics model so now
given the two readings from the sensor
we were able to predict that if we were
to apply a particular type of movement
to my fingers this is how the next image
will look like
and once we are able to use to have this
forward Dynamics model which is by the
way also how humans work
we are able to essentially plan what is
the best set of actions in order to
reach our desired goal and this actually
work very well and more importantly it
worked from raw images so we completely
sidestep the problem that a lot of
tactile sensors have that they need to
be calibrated here the robot does not
have an explicit idea of the concept of
force but through the Dynamics model
through the reward it's able to learn
what is what is good and what is bad in
terms of raw pixels and the fact that
you know if you lose the marble well
that's bad because you don't have the
pixels moving in the right place anymore
ultimately I believe that all of this
line of research on tactile sensing and
manipulation for robotics will
ultimately lead to have or I hope will
lead to have dexterous manipulation
types of skills which are on par with
humans and I think that the past is
still very long
but I I hope and believe that this is
reachable in the next decade or so
so fingers crossed which for robots is
also very hard
so to conclude this talk
um
the other effort that I mentioned
briefly and we care deeply about this
community if you are interested in
tactile sensing if you are working on
these fields we do have a website in the
slack Channel which is available for all
researchers and if you're interested I
would encourage you to register it's
really a space where researchers can
share information can share Cool results
and and can just discuss with other
people from the same field which I think
is very important
um and I of course want to thank all of
my collaborators that have been working
with me over the years these people are
extremely important in my life I you
know I love to work with with all of
them and sometimes it's
yeah it's an underappreciated how
important good collaborators are for you
know one's life
so to conclude and this is not the full
set unfortunately there are more that
you know in particular I would like to
point out Michael ambeta he has been he
is my partner in crime for everything
con concerning digit and he's uh um you
know our expert Hardware Engineers on
tactile sensing so really important
first
so to conclude
I hope I convinced that touch is a
crucial sensor modality in both humans
and and robots
and throughout the last years our goal
has been to try to create this
standardized ecosystem that can help
researchers to do research faster that
can enable people to join the field in
an easier way and in particular we have
been open sourcing a number of tools for
Hardware cheap and reliable Hardware
fast simulation and touch processing and
we really have been trying very hard to
build all of these tools by consensus by
talking interacting and trying to
support the community because we deeply
care and I duplicate as a scientist in
really supporting the scientific
community and growing it in this field
which is just now getting at the
beginning
and my personal long-term goal is to
make touch sensing more practical and
more accessible uh both for researchers
and in the real world applications
so thank you very much for your time and
I'm happy to take questions
[Applause]
I had a question so I think it's really
interesting the idea of having
multimodality through tactile sensing
and I was wondering
for the digit or such efficient-based
Sensors how do you think we could have
multi-modality in the sense that maybe
have
you know besides the high spatial
resolution have like higher frequency
signals as well yes as you pointed out
we are very multimodal sorry I cannot
hear you
oh sorry sorry uh my question
my question is uh my question was how
can we enable multimodality for tactile
sensing and in platforms like digit Yeah
you mentioned that you know DJ is a very
high spatial resolution but how can we
include the high frequency signals that
humans also have I think that would be
pretty cool yes I absolutely think this
is crucial I think that current digit
the fact that it's not multimodal is a
very big limitation to be honest it's a
big limitation of any sensor that is of
there the only sensor that I know that
is to some degree multi-model is the
biotech which also incorporates
frequency readings
um I absolutely think that this is the
path to go
um when it comes to digits specifically
you will have to wait for digit 2.0
you're here still so you have questions
yeah
and vibrations in particular are really
important for a lot of Dynamics
manipulation so I think that that's
should be a very high priority
so I was kind of curious
um
with the image based touch sensing that
doesn't seem very like intuitive to me
was that like the easiest
setup for you guys or what was what's
the advantage there in term instead of
using like
Force sensors and things like that
so the there are so first of all I agree
with you that Vision this type of images
that you get from ascensor are not as
interpretable or at least are not
characterized with the meaningful
physical
principle like forces however from a
high level point of interpretation sorry
this is back way back it's
kind of interpretable because you can
see edges you can see shapes which
humans are actually fairly good at
understanding intuitively if you
yeah like if you look at this image you
can
extract some type of information about
the geometry it's true you have
absolutely zero idea you know it was
dispressed hard or not
that educated guess not really but the
geometry part is actually fairly
intuitive for humans now
uh sorry what was the other part of your
question
I was kind of asking what was the
advantage of oh yes yes sorry I'm
getting old
um the the big Advantage is the fact
that you have unprecedented resolution a
traditional resistive or capacitive type
of sensor would probably be agreed of
maybe 100 100 maybe a couple of hundreds
uh
pixels in the same space while here you
have three hundred thousand you can do a
resolution which is two order three
order of money should higher than other
type of Technologies and and at a
fraction of the cost because this is
extremely cheap to produce
and it's extremely reliable in the sense
that a lot of these
other type of technologies have moving
part where you have cables you have
wires which over time break
the this thing what can happen is that
you break the silicon and in our in the
design of our digits the Silicon is sold
by one screw so you break the Silicon
well too bad I throw this away I put
another one
and I can keep collecting data in 30
seconds
if you're
if a resistive capacitors sensor
breakdown
chances are that you need to change the
whole Electronics so these are some of
the in my opinion very big advantages of
vision-based tactile sensors resolution
manufacturing reliability these are
pretty big items
thank you
um maybe another one which is not so
much highlighted is that
also the sensitivity of vision-based
tactile sensors
can be much higher than a capacitive or
resistive sensor because effectively you
can tune the the bandwidth the dynamic
range of your silicon based on the
application so I can make today a piece
of silicon that is able to sense
micronutrons and then tomorrow I need to
pick up oranges and I instead make a
very rugged this piece of silicon which
is in the order of you know hundreds of
Newtons and all of this can be done just
by you know again changing the this
piece of silicon that you have
okay
would the in terms of the data sets and
benchmarks do you see an advantage in
developing a data set of video Touch
data that perhaps could be helpful when
you know you're doing model based
reinforcement learning and predicting
the future states with how the Dynamics
work yes absolutely and I think that a
lot of the really interesting tasks that
we should be able to do with touch are
actually Dynamic tasks are you know
being able to rotate an object in your
hand is be able to throw something and
pick it up or whatever and all of this
tasks that requires Dynamics are of
course better suited for having temporal
type of data so having just one image is
is okay for now if you want to detect
what material you are touching or what
you are touching but it's not very
interesting from a robotic perspective
there is no Dynamic there and for for
everything that is dynamic then also the
frequency of your sampling becomes
important and
in order to truly been able to close the
loop also the decision making becomes
important so how fast can I make a
decision based on what I'm reading from
my finger and when I will start working
here with Rohan we're actually
discussing that humans have for example
a reflex arc which is extremely cool
because if you touch something that is
hot your finger will retract within
about 20 milliseconds because
the signals goes to you to your spine
and the spine essentially just activated
reflex before the signal even reach your
brain so your your finger is already you
know back before you realize oh this is
actually hot
um so being able to do this type of
closed loop fast decisions uh with touch
I think it's mind-blowing it would
revolutionize the way that we do
manipulation
thanks for the amazing talk today I
think today's talk was mainly focused on
sensing on the fingertip I'm curious
what your opinion is on the importance
of sensing on areas outside of the
fingertips say back of the hand or the
arm and how scalable and modular sensors
on those areas can look like yeah
um excellent question the way that I see
it is you know the two are complementary
in the same way that humans you know
also humans we have more sensitivity in
our fingers than let's say in our back
or in our forearm but we do need both
and in robots I believe that this is
also the case ultimately what the Golden
Growl would be is to have a you know a
robotic hand where you have very
sensitive fingertips if you want to you
know interact and sense but also to have
the full palm and the full arm and the
full you know body of your robot fully
covered the the way that I see it
um the challenges are a little bit
different because in the moment when you
are talking about skin there is much
more of a problem of scale how do I
build a skin with
you know millions of of contact points
without having to have millions of
cables
and the type of this type of vision
based technology I think would be
amazing if we could adapt it to skin but
if we look at the technology today it's
not
suitable because because of the digital
the focal distance between the camera
and your interface
this would give you a depth of about one
centimeter which is more than you want
for most artificial skin
I should point out that in in meta AI
there is a line of research also on
tactile skins so test Heller breaker has
been leading work on risking which is a
cheap
sort of low cost again
type of skin for whole body sensing so I
see that it's as complementary that
should eventually put be put together
thank you
hi uh thanks for the talk I actually
have a very similar question so it's
also regarding the mechanical aspect of
the digit sensor uh just wondering how
stable scalable it is and then you know
uh what kind of disturbance is like you
know temperature variation all those
kind of stuff would it affect the force
sensing accuracy of the sensor
who do you think you know scaling it up
let's say to a surface and that may be
installing it to a payload for payload
Transportation
um is that a possibility
um so if you if with scaling you mean
making it bigger yes area in terms of
area yes that's actually the easy part
uh in the sense that in many cases you
can
you know just change the lens change the
camera so that you can cover a larger
range of surface this is actually pretty
easy and gel site the company the
startup in Boston they actually started
from uh you know you know tools that
were for large areas
and the hard part of this type of vision
based technology is actually the
militarization mostly
um sort of just to give you a very
simple idea of how you could scale this
you know if you just take this sensor
and now you put 10 of them in parallel
uh they are all USB you can just connect
all 10 of them and now you have a sensor
which is 10 times the the dimension now
I'm not suggesting that this is
practical what would be easier is just
to move the camera a little bit farther
away which really increase
sort of the space that you're looking at
uh and you know
you can you can do this
okay thanks
yeah thank you for this like eye-opening
talk at least for me so I do like your
like example where you say that like
like in the future maybe I can ask my
sensor to say that buy this clothes as
smooth as a barcodes as smooth as this
one so then I realized that I there is
something that I don't quite understand
is that it seems like for smoothness
right I can see how this Vision based
sensors can sense like a normal pressure
but for smoothness an article seems to
also be like friction rather it's like
low friction or high frequency I wonder
what's the next state of art on the
tangential Force like sensing in this
area and like maybe what's your group's
plan on in this direction yeah yes this
is a very very good question
um for a lot of manipulation tasks Shear
forces are actually what you really care
about uh you know if you are
manipulating objects now there the way
that this Vision based tactile sensor
perceive Shear forces is through a
couple of different mechanisms one
mechanism which is very popular is that
you can essentially paint markers inside
the uh inside the silicon and as you
apply Shear forces
essentially these markers will move
around because of the of the deformation
of the gel this is an approach that for
example uh that Addison at MIT uses
extensively because once you have these
markers then you can compute Optical
flow and you essentially work in this
field of optical flow which is you know
Computing Shear forces
another possibility which we briefly
discussed is that maybe it's actually
not even necessary to use Optical
markers at all if you have a
texture some sort of texture in the in
the elastomer layer and then you can
directly look at the at the texture so
one example is that if you 3D print the
mold of this of this silicon
the the texture of the 3D printed part
will actually impress some very specific
pattern on the on the way that the light
is reflected back and just by looking at
this how this texture moves you can
compute Shear forces
um
yeah thank you